We have the number 43,249.
Now, what I want you to think
about is what these two 4's
actually represent and how
much more value is represented
by this first 4, this 4 on the
left, than this 4 on the right.
And I encourage you
to pause this video
and think about that.
So let's just think about what
each of these digits represent.
So the 9 is in the ones place.
So it literally
represents 9 ones.
This 4 on the right, I should
say, is in the tens place
so it literally represents 4
tens, or 4 times 10, or 40.
This 2 is in the hundreds
place, so it literally
represents 2 hundreds, or 200.
This 3 is in the
thousands place,
so it represents 3 thousands.
And then the 4 on the left is
in the ten thousands place.
So it literally
represents 4 times 10,000,
or 4 ten thousands, or 40,000.
So let's actually
compare the value
that we're getting
here versus here.
So what's the difference
between 40,000 and 40?
Well, 40,000 has four zeroes
while 40 only has one.
So if you wanted to
go from 40 to 40,000,
you would have to add
three more zeroes.
And we already know
how to do that.
You could add three more
zeroes by multiplying by 1,000.
So 40,000 is equal
to 1,000 times 40.
Or we could say the
4 on the left here,
this blue circled 4 represents
1,000 times the value
as the yellow circled 4.
Now, another way of
thinking about it
is every time you move
place values to the left,
as you see here-- this is
tens, hundreds, thousands, ten
thousands-- you're
increasing what those place
values represent
by a factor of 10.
So if you're going from
this 4 to this 4, times 10
times 10 times 10, you
multiply by 10 the place value.
And you see that with the
place values right over here,
the place values increase
by a factor of 10 each time.
So if you're going from
this place to this place,
and you have the exact
same digit there,
multiplying by 10 three
times is the same thing
as multiplying by 1,000.
So whatever this represents,
multiply it by 1,000,
and you're going to get
what this represents.